signe de feu la passion sera au rendez
vous et la température contraint très
vite et bien on n'a pas attendu ce test
pour savoir
[Musique]
ouais ouais c'est vrai je pense que avec
david je trouve qu'on s'est découvert
quand même un talent d'écriture assez
rare je trouve qu'en france ouais bah
des gars comme nous ça manque pour
obtenir des palmes d'or et voilà où
alors c'est ça ou un groupe de rap qu'on
avait avec un pote qui s'appelait
palmarès et du coup avec david comme on
est monté sur scène on faisait du show
on s'est dit palmashow mais ici surtout
pour la table mais c'est surtout pour la
palme d'or évidemment
alors vrai on n'est pas très loin de
chez jérôme niel donc on a à chaque fois
qu on s'appelle on se demande si on a
été faire un laser quest à coignières si
on a été à l'extrême tropicale à
coignières aussi d'ailleurs voilà c'est
une petite zone où on traînait beaucoup
et c'est vrai que les vedettes c'est
très inspiré de tout ce coin là
[Musique]
c'est complètement vrai oui avec un ami
qui s'appelle thomas il m'a appelé pour
qu'on participe à un casting pour le
bigdil et moi je me suis dit ouh là ça
peut être rigolo effectivement est en
fête bat contre toute attente on a été
pris et du coup on a été au big deal
david était dans les gradins et nous a
vus gagner à l'épreuve du kata plouf
c'était une très bonne épreuve et non
mais vous rigolez mais lequel poussent
existait vraiment on a pris des risques
et des balles en fait on a pris des
risques pour quoi pour gagner un voyage
en crète on est parti en voyage en crète
avec mon pote somme assureurs à proposer
le rideau oui mais non et vous savez ce
qu avait derrière le rideau ce appareil
photo numérique quel mauvais choix on
aurait fait
[Musique]
une chute beaucoup savaient qu'on passe
est vrai c parle souvent cette époque de
dailymotion était l'époque video star
c'était génial tous les jours on voit là
chacun se donnait à mort pour être la
vidéo star la droite il met en avant sur
la homepage jours c'était un sketch en
main ce terrible menace un mec et
l'animation avec l'apôtre de la pâte à
modeler principes et créative à savoir
une belle époque
je crois que c'est alors adoré je sais
pas en tout cas pas sûr mais nous on
fait un petit message sur twitter
avec un petit smiley les mains comme ça
c'était sympa gentil
j'avais énormément mais mais on les
écoute pas mal mais
c'est complètement rasées coupe
lentement va journée au lycée jean
monnet de la queue-lez-yvelines je crois
que c'était en 2003 ou 2004 où tu
faisais fred et je faisais jamais et il
me semble que ça c'est sûr en dvd on
avait gravé qui s'appelle comme une
première mi-temps qu'on envoyait dans
l'épreuve reine où on a vécu des
réponses négatives puis ça on en rit oui
mais un sketch sur frais et jasmin et
bien sûr 2003 ouais 2003 ou 2004 je suis
tombé sur une vidéo de jamie hier soir
on se fait mordre par un loup ah bon je
ne vous dis que ça je sais pas si vous
regardez
pourquoi je peux dire c'est que c'est
vrai idg white en mois et non il veut
faire une caresse et le mec lui dit dans
les loups surtout pas si vous mettez la
main sur un lot a voulu vérifier mais
ccrb il aventuriers quand même bien
nourri les aventuriers il a voulu faire
il a voulu se baisser entré en contact
avec le loup et le loup seuil et jamy
page amis je te bouffe la gueule petit
je pensais que j'avais été l'homme le
plus intelligent mais je pense qu'il
l'est quand même
alors ça c'est complètement faux rythme
en faut mais pas encore tout à fait
saisi le concept moi je ne les ai pas
saisies du tout du tout donc on va s'y
mettre ou est ce donc la crique de est
destinée non il faut s'y mettre ou pas
non non la non enfin pour le moment non
moi j'ai pas de collection de la naïveté
non plus
vrai ouais c'est plus en plus compliqué
de trouver des idées sans que on se dit
oh pas à temps ça va trop loin c'est un
canton paradis un fait ou une émission
de télé souvent on se dit mais le fait
dont on parlait va déjà trop loin donc
c'est dur d'aller encore plus loin et
que ce soit crédible cela dit ça offre
quand même un panel de bons personnages
bon point de départ moi ça peut faire
des bonds personnel
ac c'est vrai on avait une idée on va
donner avec david on à nous d'adapter
les tous travaux des douze travaux
d'astérix le dessin animé on rêverait de
le parce que c'est un film à sketchs
c'est vrai ça c'est un road trip en même
temps en fait c'était pas une bd c'est
vrai c'est vraiment un film c'est
vraiment un trip que sont tapés goscinny
et uderzo c'est un peu tribunaux tri
sont aptes à un peu triste ouais c'est
n'importe quoi et où alors nous on adore
aucune idée lyon et béliers
comment ça se passe une appli pour cent
alors ce qui me plaît chez toi david son
caractère passionné ses multiples
activités abattoirs tir à l'arc l'once à
voile vélo oui c'est assez vrai même si
vous n'avez pas la même énergie en
revanche vous pouvez vous retrouver sur
pas mal de buts rapport au football
évidemment si une de feu la passion sera
au rendez vous et la température contrat
très vite et bien on n'a pas attendu ce
test pour le savoir
faux
or plus les louer une technique de
manger ils viennent jamais te manger
frontalement tu sais que tu concevoir un
passionné il se met autour de toi
et j'aurais syriens pensent qu'on ne
voit pas non mais vous c'est pas aussi
malin jamie non plus